My name is Wendy Bravo.
I'm a licensed psychotherapist.
This is Katia, my daughter.
She's 11 years old.
If you want to learn Android,
definitely take
the Android Development
for Beginners class first.
They teach you really clearly,
and for those who have no idea
about programming,
they take it
step by step through.
The class really breaks down,
from the beginning,
every single thing that you need
to know to keep advancing.
And once you start doing it,
and then you get to the point
where you actually see
what you've been writing running
on your phone, it's like, "wow!".
There's this Just Java class,
where it's like
a coffee-ordering app.
I decided to take it
a little further,
add some more stuff I want to add
with my newfound knowledge.
The other piece I really like is
how they talk about making errors,
how it's part of the programming.
But the class
really makes you experience it.
And I think for me
that's the biggest difference.
When you get to experience it
and you really have
that little tension...
"OK, where is it?
How am I going to fix this thing?"
Once you actually fix it,
the more you struggle...
you feel even better then.
The instructors
make it really clear
and make it fun to learn,
at the same time.
Overall, the experience
was really great.
If I started and learned
after so many years
in a completely different career
that had nothing to do with it,
being intimidated, having all
these erroneous beliefs about it,
if even with all that
I was able to learn,
I think anyone can do it.